احتفالات تعم الاردن في زفاف الامير
الحسين توقف المحادثات بين طرفي الصراع في
السودان
مدونه سلوك اوروبيه امريكيه للذكاء
الاصطناعي
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه فاهلا بكم
افراح واحتفالات شعبيه عمت انحاء الاردن
مع بدء مراسم اول زفاف ملكي كبير في
البلاد منذ سنوات طويله وهو زفاف ولي
العهد الامير الحسين بن عبد الله الثاني
وعروسه رجوى ال سيف الحفل بدا بوصول الملك
عبد الله الثاني والملكه رانيا العبد الله
الى قصر زهران في العاصمه عمان لاستقبال
وتحيه ضيوف الحفل وبينهم ملوك وامراء
وقاده من حول العالم وبعد عقد القران خرج
العروسان في الموكب باتجاه قصر الحسينيه
حيث الاحتفال الرسمي وتضمن طريق الموكب
عددا من المحطات التي تواجد فيها
الاردنيون للمشاركه في مراسم الزفاف
بعد ساعات فقط من اعلان الجيش السوداني
تعليق المفاوضات مع قوات الدعم السريع
عبرت واشنطن عن استعدادها لاستئناف
وساقتها في السودان عندما يكون طرفان نزاع
جديين بالالتزام بوقف اطلاق النار مصادر
سودانيه قالت ان الجيش اتخذ قراره ذاك
بسبب عدم تنفيذ الدعم السريع البنده الخاص
بالانسحاب من المستشفيات ومنازل المواطنين
اضافه الى خرق الدعم المستمر للهدنه اما
على الصعيد الانساني فاعلنت الامم المتحده
ان اكثر من 100 الف لاجئ سودانيه فروا الى
تشاد منذ اندلاع النزاع في بلادهم
الى عالم الذكاء الاصطناعيه حيث اعلن كل
من الاتحاد الاوروبي والولايات المتحده عن
مشروع مشترك تحتسم مدونه سلوك لتكون متاحه
لشركات الذكاء الاصطناعي على اساس تطبيق
طووعي وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انتوني
بلينكن قال ان الهدف هو وضع قواعد سلوك
طوعيه تكون مفتوحه لكل الدول التي تتشارك
الذهنيه ذاتها في وقت يخشى الغرب من ان
تفرض الصين نهجها في هذا المجال من جانبه
اوضح الاتحاد الاوروبي وانه يسعى لوضع
يمكن شركات القطاع الذي يهيمن عليها
العمالقه الامريكيون مثل مايكروسوفت ومتى
وجوجل الالتزام به طبعا
في اخبار عالم الثروه والاثرياء استعاد
الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه تسلا ايلون ماسك
لقب الاكثر ثراءا في العالم وفقا لمؤشر
للمليارديرات متجاوزا الفرنسي بيرنار ارنو
المدير التنفيذي لشركه السلع الفخمه
سريعا خلال الاسبوع الماضي حيث بلغت ثروته
192 مليار دولار بعد صعود سهم شركته
للسيارات الكهربائيه بحوالي
65.6 بالمئه خلال العام الجاري يذكر انه
هو بحسب مؤشر بلومبرغ للمليارديرات فان كل
شخص تتجاوز ثروته 100 مليار دولار يطلق
عليهم مصطلح
خطوه فريده من نوعها اعلنت الحكومه
الكنديه
تتمثل او خطوه تتمثل بفرد طباعه تحذيرات
صحيه من مدار التبغ مباشره على كل سيجاره
في سابقه عالميه لمكافحه التدخين الخطوه
سيبدا تطبيقها في الاول من اغسطس المقبل
فيما تعد كندا اول من بدا بوضع تحذيرات
على منتجات التبغ منذ عام 2000 لتسجل
تراجعا كبيرا بالنسبه المدخنين منذ ذلك
الحين اما الخطوه الجديده فلقد ترحيبا
كبيرا من جمعيات مكافحه التدخين